the Dancing with the Stars Roadshow is
about to hit America everyone i'm danny
director at ET now the 39th city tour
kicks off two days after christmas
reigning champ Alphonso ruby arrow is
ready to go but what does dancing do for
a winner's career
I didn't want it to end you know I just
wanted to still be a part of it
judge you from these rehearsal moves
nothing stopping off on so now not even
the groin and back injuries that plagued
him during the season my body is better
I'm certainly won't say that my body is
100% back to normal it's a work in
progress the reality is is that you know
for my body to fully heal I probably
needed six weeks and I had to I've got
my own boss
and you know get to wake up with my wife
and son every morning so it's gonna be
it's gonna be wonderful
one thing Alfonso won't be breathing is
his mirror ball trophy I've got a little
mantel like kind of right in like the
foyer area of the house that you know
it's sitting on right now and you know
it's kind of light shining down on it so
like the actual you know sparkles from
the mirror you know all over the place
so it's pretty cool
Alfonso headlines the 39th city tour
which kicks off December 27th and for
when it wraps he's lining up his next
game uh we've been talking a lot with a
lot of different companies and a lot of
networks and so we're wrote we will see
what we what we accept and take and
where we go from here you will see what
what we end up I will be doing something
I guarantee you that the thing about it
is when James Avery passed I believe
that the the core of the show went with
him you know he was that rock and
there's really no reason to go back I
think in life and this is I think very
true if you're not moving forward you're
moving backwards right well boy would
that be moving backwards right that's
going way back and even doing the
Carlton dance on the show was about
paying homage to the love that that
people feel for that show and that
character and that dance but that was me
kind of saying bye Alf also already has
landed his own show on The Cooking
Channel unwrapped 2.0 he gives his take
on classic American treats and that
debuts February 2nd
you